اهلا بكم شن مسلحون مجهولون عده هجمات في
مصر استهدفت مقر امنيه في جنوب سيناء
وجنودا من الجيش قرب الاسماعيليه ومحطه
الاقمار الصناعيه في القاهره وذلك في اطار
مسلسل من العمليات مستمر منذ عده اشهر
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين تاثير تكرار مثل هذه الحوادث
الامنيه على مسيره تنفيذ خارطه الطريق
التي اعلنها
الجيش وجدل العلاقه بين الحل الامني والحل
السياسي لايجاد مخرج للازمه الحاليه في
مصر
عندما تقع ثلاثه حوادث امنيه متزامنه في
مصر بعد يوم واحد فقط من مقتل اكثر من 50
شخصا في اعمال عنف في الشارع فلا بد ان
يدق ناقص الخطر الخطر يبدو امنيا في
المقام الاول خاصه وان الهجمات استهدفت
مقر لوزاره الداخليه وجنودا من الجيش
ومنشاه مدنيه مهمه كم حطه الاقمار
الاصطناعيه لكنه ايضا يحمل في طياته
اخطارا تهدد مستقبل البلاد السياسي
المنقسم بين مسارين الاول يريد تطبيق
خارطه الطريق المعلنه والثاني يسعى لعوده
الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي الى
الحكم التطورات الامنيه المصريه تنتقل
بشكل شبه يومي من تعقيد الى تعقيد بكل
انعكاسات ذلك بعد يوم واحد من احتفالات
حرب اكتوبر استهدفت مديريه امن جنوب سيناء
بسياره مفخخه فسجلت السابقه الاولى من
نوعها في المحافظه سابقا كان شمال سيناء
خاصه المنطقه الواقعه بين مدينتي العريش
ورفح على ساحل المتوسط هو مسرح الاطرابات
الامنيه وفي اليوم ذاته وللمره الاولى
ايضا استهدفت محطه الاقمار الاصطناعيه في
حي المعادي جنوب القاهره وفي الاسماعيليه
اغتيل عدد من ضباط الجيش وجنوده اثر تعرض
سيارتهم لكمين احداث تحمل دلالات مختلفه
صحيح انها تاتي عقب مصرع اكثر من 50 شخصا
وجرح كثيرين في تظاهرات السادس من اكتوبر
المعارضه لانقلاب الثالث من يوليو لكنها
لا تنفصل عن اثر كل المشهد الامني في مصر
حاليا ومستقبلا على كل المشهد السياسي في
البلاد ولا تغيروا من الواقع تلك
الاتهامات الرسميه لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ومناصريهم منذ الانقلاب وتحملهم
مسؤوليه احداث العنف كما لا ينفي خطورتها
تاكيد الجماعه ان احتجاجاتهم سلميه وستظل
سلميه دوائر كثيره تعتقد ان النظام انصرف
الى مواجهه انشطه الاخوان ومناصريهم على
حساب واجبه الاساسي في حفظ امن البلاد
واستقرارها وعلى حساب خارطه الطريق التي
تقدم بها ومختلف طموحاتها السياسيه وتذكر
بان قادته دابوا على التاكيد بان تغييرات
الثالث من يوليو املتها المصلحه الوطنيه
للبلاد وضرورات امنها القومي وتجنيبها
حربا اهليه كانت في اعتقادهم وشيكا كيف هي
الساحه المصريه الان وما هو مصير عنوان
المصالحه الضائع بين الاحداث الدعوه الى
التظاهر ضد النظام وتصعيدها مستمره
والنظام مستعد لمواجهتها ويظل السؤال
المتعلق بامكانيه المضي في عمليه سياسيه
يرفض معطياتها قطاع واسع من الشعب كما هو
واضح في الشارع المصري حاليا يبقى مطروحا
حتى وان قيل ان تلك التظاهرات لا تعبر عن
كل
الشعب في حلقتنا هذهه معنا ضيفين في
الاستوديو هنا ياسر الهواري عضو جبهه
الانقاذ وحاتم عزام نائب رئيس حزب الوسط
والمنسق العام لجبهه الضمير قبل ان نتحول
الى ضيفين هنا في الاستديو معنا من جنوب
سيناء اللواء احمد فوزي السكرتير العام
لمحافظه جنوب سدا سنا سيد فوزي انت تصل ال
الاحداث الامنيه الان الى جنوب سيناء هل
من دلاله
لذلك سيد فوزي ايوه فندم اه نعم نعم ارجو
ان تكون استمعت الي كنت اعرف اريد ان اعرف
دلاله ان تصل الاحداث الى جنوب سيناء
والله احنا نقول حضر اخ مساء الخير على
المشاهدين اه مصر وسينا بصفه خاصه
هنا في جنوب سينا محافظه جنوب سينا محافظه
لا يوجد فيها اي مظاهر للمظاهرات او
الاعتراضات او اي شيء المدينه هادئه بتعم
بالسياحه في في مدنها الطور بالذات عاصمه
جنوب سيناء مدينه هادئه فيها المديريه
والمحافظه الامور احنا بنا يومين احتفالات
شمن المحافظه الشباب والمدارس والاولاد
والمشايخ كله فرحان
بالت
4 عام على ذكر 6 اكتوبر الى النهارده
الصبح مره واحده ودي هذه الحادثه لم تحدث
في جنوب سناء الا من ساعه التجيب بتاع
شرزه 2005 ده اللي حوالي الساعه 10 كده
وربع كده دخلت عربيه انتحاريه دخلت اتحت
ديوان عامل المديريه مديريه الامن وتفجرت
العربيه بكميه من المتفجرات كميه كبيره
جدا طبعا كانفجار سمعنا ف المحافظه
المحافظه قدام مديريه الامن كنا متواجدين
في في المحافظه طبعا حاجه صعبه وفتره
عصيبه من هذا
الانتظار الابواب طارت وش لاقي الناس
والازاز ويوا في حاجه طبعا حاجه
مدمره استش يعني سيد فوزي هل لديكم ايه
شكوك
على حول من يقف وراء ذلك والله انا من وجه
ظر كان احتك ب جنوب سينا ومشايخها وباهل
هذا الموضوع دخيل عن اهل جنوب سينا هنا
المشايخ جميع المشايخ والقبائل بذات في
جنوب سينا قمه الادب وقمه الامن وبيساعد
ونا مع القوات المسلحه ومع الشرطه في حفظ
التجمعات ناس واعيه لان هي بتحافظ على
ارضها بتحافظ على امها بتحافظ على سلامتها
بمنع دخول اي عناصر خارجه بتجينا من من اي
مكان مش عايز اقول محافظه بها ولكن طبعا
هذا العمل ده عمل خسيس عمل دخيل عمل خارج
عن نطاق جنوب سينا واهل جنوب لا يا بتت
هذا الموضوع لاهل جنوب سي جميع القبائل
كانوا معانا انا كان معايا ناس في المكتب
النهارده وقت الانفجار من
المشايخ والعيبه الفضيه السابقه
والعواد والناس كلهم المشاكل وموجودين في
المكتب وقت الانتظار عايز
اقول شكرا لك اللواء احمد فوزي السكرتير
العام لمح مظه جنوب السيناء على هذه
المشاركه سيد حاتم عزام اهم ما قاله السيد
احمد فوزي انه هذا اخطر واهم حدث في جنوب
سيدا سينا منذ تفجيرات شرم الشيخ عام 2005
وان هذا من اناس مبدئيا دخلا على المنطقه
ماذا تفهم من ذلك اولا دعي اتقدم بالعزاء
يعني
لاسر الشهداء الذين قادوا نحبهم اليوم في
هذه العمليات الاجراميه وانه ونستنكر هذا
هذا العمل الاجرامي الدخيل على الشعب
المصري الذي لا يوافق عليه اي مصري غيور
على وطن كما نتقدم بالعزاء ايضا ل 50 قتيل
قتلوا امس برصاص الجيش والشرطه في تظاهرات
سلميه يعني بانت على كل الفضائيات انها
تظاهرات سلميه الحقيقه يعني انا في غايه
القلق على بلادي من هذا الاتون الذي تسير
اليه وانا احمل قاده الانقلاب العسكري بعد
3 يوليو المسار الذي اصبحت فيه مصر الان ا
الحقيقه المسار الذي صارت فيه مصر
الديمقراطي كان برعايه المجلس العسكري من
وضعه عقب ثوره يناير هو المجلس العسكري من
حمل الانتخابات الخمس استحقاقات
الانتخابيه هو المجلس العسكري من عين لجنه
التعديلات الدستوريه هو المجلس العسكري من
قال نحن نسلم البلاد الحكم المدني هو
المجلس العسكري ف ف سنتين كاملين نبني في
ديمقراطيه ثم يطيح بها الفريق السيسي في
3/7 لتشهد مصر في ثلاث شهور عدد قتلى لم
تشهدها في خلال حروبها ابدا يعني عدد
القتلى الان تجاوز الالاف يعني في المصادر
الرسميه 2000 مثلا ممكن تلاقيها 2000 1000
في ربعه والنهضه وغيرهم مبارح 50 انما
المصدر الحقيقي 5000 قتيل غير المسجونين
غير هذا المسار ضد الديمقراطيه الذي يستلب
من الناس هو ايضا ليس فقط ضد الديمقراطيه
كما تقول ولكن ايضا هو مربك وهنا اسال سيد
هواري مربك لخريطه الطريق لان يفترض
القياده الجديده بعد الثالث من يوليو وضعت
خارطه الطريق باستحقاقات معينه عندما تدخل
البلاد في احداث من هذا القبيل ما تاثيره
على الاستحقاقات من دستور من انتخابات من
ميثاق شرف للعالمين من كل الخطوات الاخرى
خليي بس ال
يعني يسال في مساله تعطيل المسار
الديمقراطي م يقون بمثل هذه الاعمال
المخربه يعني يعني خليي اوصني على كلام
المهندس حاتم لما ارسل العزاء للجميع زي
ما بالضبط عزينا الاسر الضحايا امبارح
وبالمناسبه يعني انا لازم بقول ان الضحايا
امبارح ما كانوش بس اخوان يعني كان الضحيه
من الطرفين لانه كانت الاشتباكات وغالب
الشهداء امبارح سقطوا باشتباكات ما بين
الاهالي والاخوان ما كانش ما كانتش بين
الاخوان والشرطه والجيش عشان دي بس دي دي
حاجه مهمه لازم الناس كانش فقط بين الشرطه
ما كانتش فقط بين كانت معظمها ما بين
الاهالي وما بين الاخوان اللي كان للاسف
بعضهم كان في اطراف المسيرات كان بعضهم
مسلح وكان شايل س دي نمره واحد نمره
اثنين المهندس حاتم ارسل زيه لاسر الضحايا
والحقيقه ان دي يعني انا على مدار اليوم
النهارده قاعد بسمع ناس بتتكلم عن اللي
حصل امبارح وما شفتش حد يعني بعت بركيه
عزا واحده للناس ولا كان الجنود الغلابه
دول اللي بيموتوا دول ما لهمش تمن يعني
كان دمهم زي ما احنا بنتكلم على الدم اللي
بيراك في التظاهرات وبنقول ده دم حرام
وانه لا يجب انه يتم معاقبه من يخرج
للتظاهر انه يتقتل او كذا كمان الجندي
البسيط اللي بيادي خدمته العسكريه في مكان
خدمته ده لا يجب ان هو تمتد ليه اليد
بالغدر ده وتقتله انا بصني بصني على كلام
المهندس حاتم الحقيقه وكلام محترم في ما
يتعرق بخليط الطريق انا انا بعتقد انه
المساله ستكون اكثر صعوبه لكنها لن تؤدي
في النهايه الى ان هي تنتهي تماما لانه
لجنه الدستور شغاله مالهاش علاقه باللي
بيحصل خالص وهيطلع المنتج بتاعهم في اقرب
فرصه ان شاء الله والمنتج ده يجب الا يحدث
معه كما حدث مع دستور 2012 الخطا اللي حدث
مع دستور 2012 انه لم يحدث نقاش مجتمعي
حول
ما خرج من الدستور يجب على المنتج اللي
هيخرج من لجنه ال 50 انه لا يسب الاستفتاء
مباشره وانه يتعمل عليه حوار مجتمعي طويل
مساله انه يتعطل الديمقراطيه او تتعطل
خريطه الطريق او تتعطل الانخابات عشان
خاطر في احداث بتحصل لا يجب ان ده يحدث
تماما بالعكس ده اللي هينه على الاحداث
ديت الاسراع في عوده المؤسسات المنتخبه
وعوده
الديمقراطيه
يجب ويجب الاسراع هذا باعتبارك ولكن عاده
وهنا اسال سيد حاتم عزام عاده اي دوله
عندما تصبح عرضه لتحديات امنيه من هذا
القبيل تؤجل ما عداها من ملفات وهذا حدث
في اكثر من تجربه هل بتقديرك يخشى ان يصبح
محاربه هذه الظواهر الامنيه هي الشغل
الشاغل للجيش ولامن وللدول المصريه ككل
وبالتالي استعاده المسار الديمقراطي او
خارطه الطريق حتى بالتحفظ التي لديكم لن
تجد لها مجالا انا متفق تماما يعني لا
توجد شيء اسمه ديمقراطيه في مصر الان
والاتجاه ليس في اتجاه الديمقراطيه وبعدين
حضرتك بتقول لي مسار لخريطه الطريق طب مين
اللي قعد عن هذا المسار الفريق السيسي
قائد الانقلاب العسكري الذي تلاه في 3/7
طيب ما هو بقول لحضرتك المجلس العسكري بعد
ثوره يناير هو الذي وضع خارطه الطريق
الاستفتاء هو الذي حمل الانتخابات طيب انا
عايز اد انا عايز ادل من هنا اقصد ان اذا
لم تكن هناك اذا كان الجو
هادئ فالمجلس ف القياده الجديده قادره ان
تذهب قدما الان ربما تتحج في اشكاليه حتى
لو الجو هادي الاشكاليه انت كيف تثق في من
انقلب على هذا المسار الذي رعاه هو بنفسه
ثم انقلب عليه كيف تطالب من الشعب ان يثق
في هذا المسار انت عندك اشكاليه
حقيقيه نمره اثنين كل الارهاصات التي حتى
قيلت في خارطه الطريق كانت النهارده
المجلس العسكري يفعل وقض الانقلاب عكسها
يعني تحدثوا عن ميثاق شرف اعلامي لا يطبق
بل تغلق القنوات وهناك قنوات تمارس
التحريض حتى الان لم تغلق تحدثوا عن
الحريات وعوده الحريات و والناس تقتل وهي
تتظاهر وانا اصحح معلومه قيلت لا قتل امس
في شاب مسيحي قتل امس في 50 واحد قتل امس
ليسوا من الاهالي الاهالي لم يقتلوا شيء
ما فيش اهالي معاهم سلاح الي السلاح الالي
مع والطلق الرصاص الحي كان مع قوات الشرطه
والقوات المسلحه واحنا شفنا في فيديوهات
هم يطلقون الاعيره الناريه على المتظاهرين
لابسين اسود وراهم ب خلينا في التداعيات
خلينا في التداعيات انا بقول لك بدايه لا
توجد هناك ثقه من الشعب المصري من انا انا
انا بقول انه اكثر من ثلثين الشعب المصري
الذي صار في كل هذه الاستح الديمقراطيه لا
يثق في قضه الانقلاب ويتظاهر طالبا بعوده
المسار الديموقراطي والثقه او عدم الثقه
يفترض ان تتجلى في الاستحقاقات المقبله
اذا اذا جرت انتخابات وكان الاقبال ضعيف
هذا دليل عدم ثقه يعني من الصعب ان نزم
الان لا الثقه الثقه وعدم الثقه تتجلى في
حاجتين في التجربه يعني انت بقول لك صرت
معايا خمس استحقاقات قلت انا بسلم البلاد
ومشيت معايا وانت لو ععت خر الطريق وانت
اللي حميت الانتخابات وكنت تتب ب كده ثم
انقلبت عليها
فمبدأ
على تنفيذها حتى وان كانت تسير جنب الى
جنب مع مقاومه هذه الاحداث انا ما عنديش
شك تماما انه القياده الم الموجوده دلوقتي
هتسلم السلطه في اقرب موعد يمكن معه تحديد
مكن يمدد نظرا لهذه الاحداث اعتقد اعتقد
انه اعتقد ان هناك حرص لا اعتقد ان هناك
حرص على عدم اعطاء اي فرصه لمن يتحدث عن
وجود انقلاب حدث في مصر او غيره بانه ياخذ
مساله التمديد ديت وياخدها ذريعه على انه
ياكد كلامه على انه في انقلاب انا اثق
تماما بانه سيتم الانتهاء من اعداد مشروع
الدستور ثم يتم تحديد موعد للانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئيسيه انا لا ما عنديش شك
تماما مساله اللي حصل امبارح في فيديوهات
برض في المقابل بتجيب جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وفي المسيره بتاعتهم وهم شايلين
سلنا برض في التداعيات وليس في ما ج يعني
كتف صغير كده الدون المشي فلازم ارد فيعني
فلا في فيديوهات بتقول انه الطرف الاخر
كان يحمل الاسلحه والفيديوهات موجوده على
اليوتيوب وممكن كل الناس تخش شوف مثل ما
هناك دائما في مصر وفي كل الاحداث روايتين
مختلفتين هناك ايضا جدليه في العلاقه بين
الحل الامني والحل السياسي بعد الفاصل
سنحاول التعرف الى اي مدى يمكن التوفيق
بين الامرين لن عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان
تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها مستجدات
الوضع الامني في مصر والانعكاسات المحتمله
على المشهد السياسي سيد حاتم عزام هل لديك
اي تخوفات بان التوجه نحو الحلول الامنيه
سيمس اي محاوله لمعالجه سياسيه لما يجري
الان انا لدي يقين الحقيقه لدي يقين انه
هذه الممارسات العسكريه البوليسيه تطمس كل
الحلول السياسيه حتى يعني انا ادي حضرك
مثال العقلاء الذين يملكون مفاتيح الحلول
السياسيه حتى للتفاوض والتفاهم معتقلون
يعني اعتقل واحد زي ابوو العلا ماضي وهو
له ما له من وسطات وسط الطيارات السياسيه
المختلفه الدكتور سعد
الكتاتني يعني كثيرين انا حتى بقول لك
يعني من يصنفونه ان هم حمائم السلام بين
دي نمره واحد نمره اثنين انه الممارسات
التي تتم بعد الانقلاب العسكري كلها
ممارسات بوليسيه وعسكريه يعني الاعتقالات
تتم على الراي على اساس الراي ثم يتم
تلفيق جريمه جنائيه عشان خاطر يقول لك ده
مش معتقل سياسي ده معتقل قانوني انا اعتقد
انه مصر الان تحتاج الى حل سياسي نم
بالاساس الحل السياسي من وجهه نظرنا في
التحالف الوطني لدعم الشرعيه هو عوده
الديمقراطيه التي ذهب الى بنائها الشعب
المصري عوده المسار الديمقراطي كاملا ثم
نستطيع ان نضع العديد من الحلول يعني يمكن
يمكن ان يعود الدستور المستفتى عليه من
المصريين يا اخي انت امامك لجنه الان ولكن
الا يبدو الا يبدو هذا الحل السياسي انتهى
انتهى بمعنى ان الاحداث لم تعد تسمح له
بان يطل ان يطل براسه على الاطلاق من وجهه
نظري الاسماء ما يحدث الان يفرض هذا الحل
لانه انت يعني الفريق السيسي قال ا انه هو
بينحذف الشعب المصري الشعب المصري
النهارده على مدار يعني داخلين في 100 يوم
اكثر من 90 يوم الان بيتظاهر في الشوارع
بالملايين ويقتل ويسجن عشان خاطر رايه ولو
كان السيسي يمتلك قوه حجه سياسيه واراده
وفعلا تمكين شعبي ما كانش يمنع ميدان
التحرير من الدخول لمتظاهرين ليه كان كانش
يغلق ال القنوات ما كانش يعتقل ما كانش
يقتل هذا دليل على انه الحاله الشعبيه
العامه في مصر ترفض هذا الانقلاب وبالتالي
هؤلاء الناس يا سيدي وضعوا اصواتهم في
الصناديق يريدون ان يحترمونها وهذا العالم
كله يريده فنحن نقول انه الحل السياسي هو
الاساس في مصر وعوده الدوله البوليسيه
الامنيه ليس هو الحل بل هو مزيد من
التعقيد الامور واحنا بنشوف انه عوده
الشرعيه الدستوريه وعوده الرئيس المنتخب
ثم يستطيع الرئيس ان يفوت سلطاته ل وزاره
او حكومه ائتلاف وطني موسع ويعلن عن موعد
الانخابات الرئاسيه نعم ولكن ولكن اسمح لي
هل الحل السياسي وانا اعود للسيد ياسن اول
هل الحل
السياسي سيبتعد وجوبا لان اذا شعرت
الاجهزه الامنيه والجيش بان التحدي الامني
يفرض عليها ان تكون صلبه وتضرب بيد من
حديد وهو التعبير المستعمل في كثير من
المناسبات او كلمه افرم يا سيسي او كذا هل
هذا يجعل الاجهزه غير مستعده لحلول سياسيه
لان اصبح منطق مع التحديات الامنيه يفرض
منطق مختلف تماما طيب هي افم يا سيسي دي
المقابل بتاع اقضب يا ريس اللي كان
بيقولوها جماعه الاخوان في وقت من الاوقات
اعتقد ان هي هي نفس المقابل يعني انا انا
ما سمعتش كتير قوي في رومسيس لكن سمعت ضس
كتير لا حتى حتى ان بلال فضل كتب فيها
مقال جميل انه انه المشكله الان في في
مصصر
بين بين بين بؤس
الاخطاء وبين افرم يا سيسي ك ك انا انا
بقول انه لا يجب ان يعلو الصوت الامني فوق
الصوت السياسي وانه لا يجب ان يتم تعطيل
عوده
الديمقراطيه بذري الاحداث اللي بتحصل كل
يوم والحقيقه انه من يطالب بعوده
الديمقراطيه يجب ان يكون اكثر الناس حرصا
عليها واذا كانت الناس بتتكلم على
استحقاقات انتخابيه تم اهدارها انا بعتقد
ان اللي اهدر الاصقات الانتخابيه هو من لم
يحترم وجوده على الكرسي بشكل قانوني يعني
لما تبقى انت رئيس الجمهوريه ولا تحترم
احكام القضاء ولا تحترم المحاكم نفسها
وتبعث بمعارض بمؤيد انك عشان يحص والمحاكم
انت كده اهدرت شرعات القانونيه وبالتالي
لا شرعيه قانونيه لك ومساله ان وجودك يعني
كرئيس منتخب سقطت قانونيا من بعد ما من
بعد ما انت طلعت اعلان دستوري سيد عزام
اشار الى نقطه مهمه وهو وهي ان العقلاء
الان ويح او ابع بتقديرك الان الوضع في
مصر مازال يتيح مجال لعقلاء يتحركوا بين
منطقين يبدو ان كل واحد مصر على على انا
بعتقد انه يجب ان يكون هناك عقلاء من
الطرفين يحاولوا يعملوا رقب للصدع ولكن ده
مش معناه انه ترك من من اجرم بدون عقاب
يعني فكره انه يبقى في مصالحه طبعا لازم
يبقى في مصالحه بس مع مين هي الفكره كلها
انك بتتصالح مع اللي ما شالش سلاح او اللي
عايز يشتغل سياسه بشكل ما هواش ماهوش في
عنف لكن اللي اجرم واللي حرد على العنف
وكذا وكذا لا زم بتحاسب لانه دي مسائل دي
في دم سقط من الجانبين كل ده لازم لازم كل
واحد فينا ياخد حقه من اللي اجرب لكن هل
هناك تخوفات هل هناك تخوفات اسمحي سيد
هوار هل هناك تخوفات من ان هذا المنطق
سياسي سينحسر تدريجيا اذا ما استمرت
العمليات واذا ما استمرت الاجهزه الامنيه
بالطبع في التصرف في انا اخشى انا اخشى ان
الصوت العاقل دايما بيخف طول ما بيبقى
فييه زخم في الاحداث الدمويه يعني انت لما
بنتكلم على لما لما بنقول فكره مصالحه
وبعدين يطلع الطرف اللي احنا عايزين
نتصالح معاه ده يطلع شايل سلاح تاني يوم
فالا جزه الامنيه تتصدى فيقع قتلى من
الجانبين ويقع صراع فبالتالي انصار الحل
الامني هم اللي هيبقى صوتهم اعلى ده ده ده
شكل ب شيء طبيعي يعني عندما عندما يقول
عندما يقول الفريق السيسي
سيد عزام ان الجيش والشرطه والشعب يد
واحده الشعب والجيش والشرطه الش الشعب
الشعب والجيش والشرطه اوك سيدي بالترتيب
هذا الشعب والجيش والشرطه عندما يصبحوا
هؤلاء جميعا يد واحده تقديرك هل هذا يجعل
امكانيه ايه
ايه يعني بلوره حل سياسي صعبه جدا في ضوء
ثلاثيه ترى انه من ال من الواجب وضع حد
لاي تحركات مخله بالامن لاحظ انه الفريق
السيسي يدافع عن الانقلاب الذي قام به
وانا نسيت اقول انه طبعا الحل السياسي
اللي انا بتكلم عنه ده لن ياتي يعني مره
واحده كده لابد من مراحل متعدده الاول
رسائل ايجابيه ترسل للاطراف بالافراج عن
المعتقلين السياسيين الحاجه الاهم محاسبه
قاده الانقلاب يعني الفريق السيسي يجب ان
يقدم بالمحكمه بتهمتين رئيسيتين اول حاجه
الانقلاب على الشرعيه الدستوريه
والديمقراطيه ثاني شيء المسؤوليه المباشره
عن قتل الال ولكن يا سيد عزام خلينا نكون
منطقين انسان ماسك بالبلد هو
وفريقه يقدم يقدم للعداله في ضو في ضوء
المعات الح هل تطلب حضرتك انه 5000 قتيل
دول دمهم يروح حضر لا انا لا لا لا لا
اقصد بالمنطق الريل بولتك ما ريل بوتيك لو
انت بتتكلم ر بوتكس الثورات لا تعترف منطق
التوامات اللي حضرتك بتقولها دي يعني زي
ما مبارك ها وكان الناس بتقول لا طب خلوه
يقعد لغايه شهر سبتمبر بس وهسلم السلطه ما
حصلش الكلام فيجب ان تتم محاكمه الفريق
السيسي لانه السيسي الان يمارس الاوامر
التي تقتل الشعب عندما تدعو الى ذلك انت
تجعل القياده السياسيه الجديده اكثر شراسه
في التعامل لان يعني يا تكون يا ما تكونش
انا بقول لك انه انه حضرتك سالتني سؤال
نعم هل فريق السيسي بيقول كده ليه انا
بقول لك لان هو بيدافع عن موقفه لابد ان
يعلم اصل انت النهارده الذي اعطى اوامر
بالقتل وانقلب عسكريا يعلم تمام العلم انه
على المحك سيحاسب لا ما حاله ف السيسي
الان يدفع بمؤسسات الدوله كلها للحفاظ على
نفسه شخصيا ولذلك يطلق مثل هذه التصريحات
ت ترى ذلك سيد هواري لا يعني انا شايف انه
الفريق ع الفتاح السيسي يعني ما كانش مضطر
ان هو يقوم ما قام به الا لما شاف انه
البلد داخل على حرب اهليه يعني الراجل
يعني اكثر من مره كان يتكلم في فكره انه
ولكن عندما واحد يهرب من حرب اهليه الى
حرب اهليه شو سوينا في النهايه حربه لا
طبعا لا طبعا لما يعني يذهب من شيء محتمل
الى شيء الان يجري لا ما يحدث الان ليست
حرب اهليه يعني اقصد سمح الله ليست حرب
اهليه اقصد انه هرب كان داخ على حرب لكن
البلد بحكم الاخوان كانت داخله على حرب
اهليه فعلا تدخل الجيش انا انا انا بقول
انه الجيش في 30/6 عندما تدخل كان تدخلا
لانه طرف خارج الازمه يعني الازمه
السياسيه اساسا ما كانتش بين الاخوان وبين
الجيش كانت الازمه بين الاخوان وبين
المعارضه الجيش تدخل كطرف في النص يحاول
ان هو ما
انتقب الازمه فيعني الجيش هنا تدخل كطرف
بره الازمه خالص وقال حتى قبل 30/6 باسبوع
قال انه يجب على الاطراف السياسيه ان هي
تدخل في مفاوضات مع بعض والا البلد
هروق نص دقيقه الجيش لا يجب ان يتدخل في
العمل السياسي ومطالبتها بعود الجيش عن
العمل السياسي ده ده مطلب رئيسي الحاجه
الثانيه السييسي لم يتم قتل هؤلاء القتلى
في عهد رئيس منتخب وفي عهد ديمقراطي ولكن
تم هذا كله بعد الاقلاب شكرا لك حاتم عزام
شكرا ايضا ياسر الهواري وبطبع نشكر ضيفنا
الذي كان معنا عبر الهاتف اللواء احمد
فوزي في امان
الله